[Music]
when you look from above you can see
that our sonorities scattered across
Mexico's Yucatan Peninsula you know
everywhere you go around here find these
holes the cold say notice there's
thousands of them and most of them
haven't even been explored Wow when I
get there size of that
this is magnificent that's beautiful
so lower the gear please there's
actually much more to this amazing
cavern than first meets the eye
but to understand the scale of what
happened here you have to go deeper
still underwater descending into the
depths of the sonority is like entering
a new world fewer people are visited
some of these drone caverns and the
surface of the Moon as divers have
explored further they've discovered the
cenotes are actually part of a huge
complex of tunnels and caves
[Music]
and when they're mapped it becomes clear
that they follow a distinctive circular
course through the jungle they mark out
the rim of a giant crater scientific
instruments show the structure of the
underlying rock has been deformed
revealing the boundaries of a colossal
meteorite impact crater the meteorite
was likely over nine miles across enough
to cause utter devastation across the
whole planet it exploded with the force
of 100 million million tons of TNT
the blast said the giant plume of
vaporized rock out into space a crater
was punched half a mile into the Earth's
crust it was above this realm of
weakened rock that this cenote is formed
[Music]
the blasts would have been ferocious
the blast plume that shot into space
fell back to earth
many believe that billions of molten
particles superheated the air to
hundreds of degrees fire swept the
planet choking the atmosphere with soot
and dust the dinosaurs and most other
creatures were doomed
[Music]
but fortunately underground there were
some survivors
it took a few million years but
eventually conditions are not returned
to normal by wiping out the dinosaurs
the impact cleared the way for the rise
of a new type of animal the mammals and
ultimately for humans so from our point
of view this global disaster turned out
to be no bad thing